la ville de versailles s'est transformé
en théâtre à ciel ouvert le temps du
mois de juin
objectif proposer des rendez vous
culturels accessibles à tous à travers
la ville
près de 50 spectacles sont organisés
dans plusieurs lieux de la cité comme
les grandes écuries ou encore l'académie
internationale des arts du théâtre
vous avez également le jardin des
musiciens italiens où il ya des concerts
de landes organise mai et puis vous avez
aussi un théâtre privé à versailles
notre volonté toujours a été de d'avoir
des spectacles de qualité qui sont
accessibles à tous le domaine des grands
chênes fait partie des lieux du festival
au programme une série de spectacles
dédiés aux arts du spectacle vivant et
des multiplexes de théâtre j'avais vie
et quatre ailiers champ cultivé dans le
même temps et avec les cheveux taquet
choix que la chique quechua
contemporaine et choix dès mi mai et où
les tous les théâtres une bonne
opportunité pour les jeunes comédiens de
l'académie internationale des arts du
spectacle
une édition particulière qui leur permet
de jouer davantage
l'an dernier le molière ont joué que le
week end est là avec qu'ovide toute
restrictions sanitaires le molière s'est
restreint allied à ces deux autres lieux
dans versailles et du coup nous a dit
bah on va en profiter on va jouer tous
les joueurs donc on joue encore plus
qu'avant
objectif de l'événement rendre la
culture accessible à tous plusieurs
milliers de spectateurs ont déjà profité
de l'occasion
si nous en avions la disponibilité nous
participerions bien sûr en tant que
spectateur bien plus souvent que
qu'aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai qu'un
début c'est vraiment une très belle
opportunité de faire jouer et découvrir
les jeunes comédiens parce que c'est une
opportunité vraiment de découvrir un
certain nombre de pièces
on n'irait pas forcément voir soi-même
au théâtre encore une vingtaine de
spectacles à venir parmi lesquels carmen
la vie parisienne ou encore les
travailleurs de la mer plus
d'informations sur le site de la ville
encore